хаски allman і разу не команд он вона
слухається господаря з радості чіпляється
дані знаємо team
у того alma вуса одну завищується у будь-якої
націю ще раз у батчата свого собаку
кіборг з позивним вальтером ріпу на його
щит не були на сході України поспішаю 20 см
і річкові ти раз викликали у слов'янську
краматорська
взводом донецький аеропорт, що зайшов нам
вівці тубу земля
Замість води раз стали б рулькою поміти
гарячу речі сухпаяння
холод вітер його рошку чи інший ващі
астані не де
побачимо купу і віч обліку кікал і бетоні
перекриття будемо лєру іншу ца еш матки
бетонного то грам по сто п'ятдесят
підвести падають вниз і вібрацією припусти
будемо лекал і точково запропонує тобі
труси
ну студії в польщі раз подумавши з і фініш
ви двоє ворсу мальта рст вам виразом
сувенірний календарик кіборга рік тому
у волонтерському штаби гвинта його побратим
ставити автографи
то раз по раз зіграти армійським і жар
там і на глянець і dect об'єктив вже у
у аліни вольтер вина мага все
повернулися я думаю та мужики та сліду
мобілізації безшовно свою роботу
менеджером ми облаву компанію ось на до
через Європу зірки все винного жає з
психологічну травму че проблему з
адаптації після прожитого кіборг просто
поважаючи чого вам місяця на сході України
я рибалю себе в цивільному вже ті
скажімо ось так ми не личить камуфляж
зброя
захист розпорядження та адреналін там у
рапорту за вийшла вона вище юргіс
приводи align і ви куна не завдання адже
нові то кордони україна 90 паршиво
уроку тушки брахми вирішив служити їм
віддали в армії за контрактом хочеться
рахунок пуску виріши вже направив його відра
джона про приблизно так перейшло дефенса
годину жити, а в мирному Києві вимагали
хати тому